alright guys so in the past we've talked
a lot about twitch bands on this show
people getting banned for crazy [ __ ]
they've said people getting banned for
crazy [ __ ] they've done and people
getting banned for [ __ ] they haven't
said or done but today's a bit different
imagine if you will through no fault or
intent of your own you will prone to say
things that could be insulting that
could be derogatory that could break
twitches tos and definitely get you
banned well that is the reality that a
streamer called sweet Anita
faces every time she streams and lately
it's caused a few problems for her
okay so some of you guys have already
heard about Sweden eita she's a variety
streamer she's on just chatting a lot
and she happens to have Tourette's
syndrome but what is Tourette's syndrome
well the Mayo Clinic defines it as quote
a disorder that involves repetitive
movements or unwanted sounds tics that
can't be easily controlled for instance
you might repeatedly blink your eyes
shrug your shoulders or blurt out
unusual sounds or offensive words
end quote more on that last part a
little later now anita has had a hell of
a year and a half on twitch and youtube
over the last year alone her followers
and subscribers have taken off her
youtube subs and views have steadily
climbed her discord has grown to 25,000
people and her average total twitch
views have skyrocketed and it's not hard
to see why she initially catches a lot
of people's attention yes she is
well-spoken she's super friendly and
infectiously positive but you wouldn't
realize those things until you'd spent a
little time in her stream the first
thing you noticed if you were to google
sweet anita or check out her YouTube or
go on reddit are some of her more
extreme vocal tics I do play the forest
I play Bioshock I play with my dick on a
Tuesday [ __ ] you and Jesus [ __ ] you
[ __ ] lasagna [ __ ]
lasagna [ __ ] lasagna now if you find
yourself suppressing a little grin or
giggling to yourself watching that clip
don't feel too guilty
I spoke to Anita yesterday for this
video and she is open unashamed and
again infectiously positive about the
reaction she gets she gets it yeah it's
totally fine
I'm a tiny little woman screaming at the
top of my lungs about a dick I clearly
don't have of course that's ridiculous
of course that's funny I know it's
ridiculous and I'm perfectly fine with
other people seeing it that way too
and to be honest I grew up being treated
quite harshly for my condition and with
no diagnosis and no way to explain what
was going on people treated me as if
those actions were intentional and that
was really hard I'm really scary and it
stopped me from being able to get public
transport safely and it stopped me from
engaging with the world and I became I
prefer Beck because of it so when people
laugh I'm relieved because it's much
less of a harsh reaction than I
rock used to and it diffuses the tension
and the fear that maybe they're offended
so I find laughter and absolute relief
and the way I see it to be honest is
that people can spend like 30 odd years
of their lives trying to become a
comedian when they're totally not funny
and I got gifted with the passive
ability to make people chuckle without
even trying how could I not see that as
a good thing you know how could I not
see making people silence a good thing
and if that is the reason you find
yourself watching Sweden eat a stream
for the first time she did explain to me
that that's not necessarily the reason
that people keep coming back it's the
people that arrived haven't asked a few
questions about Tourette's and left
they've stayed and it's very easy to get
bored of just someone shouting the same
swear words over and over again so yeah
well a lot of people like to atribute my
success to you my condition and
beginning to see that to be honest is
kind of a bit of a side note and the
stuff that I'm really connecting with my
audience over is probably more mental
health oriented and more to do with just
the struggles of life and you know
muddling through them together now they
say that all publicity is good publicity
but last week in a now-deleted tweet a
streamer by the name of little chipmunk
reacted to a clip of a need of uttering
a phrase that in a vacuum devoid of
context is pretty offensive this tweets
and another now-deleted response in
which little chipmunk implies that the
comment might in some way be intentional
started a shitstorm on social media
reddit Twitter twitch it was everywhere
thousands of people who didn't
understand the nature of living with
Tourette's syndrome or neurological
disease sent a need a terrible messages
and it won't take long for you to find
articles or threads calling for her to
be banned but many others rallied to her
defense and explain the condition for
those who aren't in the know and in
about 24 hours
things went full circle Anita's
supporters dropped some knowledge little
chipmunk learned what was up and
apologized and her boyfriend of small
streamer by the name of summit 1g he may
have heard of added his voice to the
chorus and apologized on behalf of
little chipmunk to Anita and I just
wanted to give an apology to Sweden Nita
I hope I hope you're doing okay through
all through all the [ __ ]
[Music]
you're killing it on twitch keep it up
and keep trucking through it honestly
and I apologize if me or the girlfriend
of cause anymore you know [ __ ] then
you needed to go through the root of
this entire drama is ignorance and
speaking of which for anyone who's not
getting it yet it goes like this some
people who live with Tourette's syndrome
can experience complex vocal tics which
are categorized as coprolalia basically
it means you say or repeat taboo or
offensive language involuntarily
in other words guys Anita is not
dropping [ __ ] lasagnas on purpose or
just for the hell of it I forgave her I
took her apology I have faced a lot of
people who've misunderstood me
throughout my life I have been starved
and punished I have had experienced
aggression I have been actinide access
to education I've been kicked off public
transport all sorts of things and I'm
not angry
I am grateful now that I get a platform
to get people talking about Tourette's
and informing each other and I love that
and reddit has transformed when I
arrived a year ago a year and a half ago
people all will go and she's fake she's
Cartman she's fake and now with every
single clip people are having a really
healthy normal discussion about
Tourette's and anyone calling me fake is
downvoted and then things are explained
to them in a really patient and really
informative manner I love that because
that makes the world a safer place for
people Tourette's that understanding
means everything but that was just one
controversy one instance of a vocal tic
or coprolalia
being taken the wrong way by someone who
didn't understand the context but what
if it happens again hell how do you
stream on Twitch when it's possible even
likely that you may uh tur through no
fault of your own some pretty
problematic [ __ ] oh yeah they're people
who subscribe for months just to bought
me and sperm in my chat whilst I'm
streaming these words we had it happen
this morning
someone's said will you call me the
n-word and I hope had like thousands of
black counts flood my am my stream
midway through and I've just gotten um
to it's been happening since the
beginning but Anita told me that for
every negative [ __ ] who does some
like that there are plenty more who are
just holy positive and friendly the kiss
well the Internet's a farm will hold
some place they would like to give it
credit for and even though there are a
lot of people who are being cruel
thousands of thousands of people I still
feel like the overwhelming majority of
people have been really supportive and
kind I think if that wasn't the case
maybe a lot of the apologies and a lot
of the people talking and opening these
discussions maybe all that stuff
wouldn't happen if it weren't for the
fact that people tend to be far more
warm-hearted and loving and
understanding on the internet than we'd
like to initially think I know I
certainly wouldn't be here were it not
for that as far as the platform itself
goes as twitch is so fond of saying when
it comes to banning people not banning
people breaking the tos it's all about
context and when it comes to the context
of living with Tourette syndrome Anita
says that which is actually pretty
understanding of the fact that these
tics are not her fault and there is no
malice intended behind them I did talk
teat which i detoxed which I think I
didn't have to explain my condition to
them it'll that it feels like they did
their own research I make their own
judgments about me but I do engage with
them and I do check in with them and
they're very open with me for example
vods clips with racial slurs and
homophobic slurs things like that I'll
check in with them ago do I need to
delete these do I need to delete every
single word where this happens because I
may not be able able to have any vods
for the next few months I don't know
when this takes gonna go away and
they're like clarifying the it's not
intentional and things like that and
there is a tick and I couldn't prevent
it and like yep at this point context
and twitch bands is almost a meme but in
this case we can actually see that lip
service that oft-repeated phrase of it's
all about the context actually come to
fruition actually be applied correctly
and transparently in a real case now
some of you might still be sitting here
saying well Colin if so-and-so gets
banned for uttering such and such a
phrase and Anita utters the same phrase
get banned too right it's only fair well
Anita has a response for that she says
you're basically asking for tampons no
just just watch the clip it is
completely separate and I have had
people say react to my content and the
tics that are really inappropriate and
say things like well if she's allowed to
say it they have to be consistent
neither let all of us say what everyone
will ban her and the thing is I kind of
feel like that's like your little
brother telling your mom that she has to
buy him tampons too it's like you don't
need them yes it would be fair but you
can control what you say so you don't
need these allowances so even with a
cursory understanding of Tourette's
syndrome and coprolalia even with all
the positivity that just emanates from
Sweden EDA and her stream there are
people out there who do think she should
not be allowed on the platform it may
not be her fault they say but if she's
liable to say things that break twitches
tos she shouldn't be allowed to stream
well if that's what you're thinking now
Anita says she's doing good for her
community good for twitch and good for
the Internet at large and after
consuming a lot of her content and
talking to her over the last few days I
kind of have to agree yo ok ok ok look
ok ok I'm already bringing the heat I'm
not even rapping yo I'm doing don't add
me like my name was Keith cap stick the
difference between me and him is that I
rap SiC if you see me at an event go
ahead and give me DAPs quick but if
you're a Twitter hater if you're a
little esport wiener masturbator and you
can [ __ ] off
boom